Hello and welcome to fire of learning.
This is the fourth and final Myra is very cyber analysis video.
In this video we're going to be talking about the least common category of the
nts,
the intuitive thinkers,
the ENTP,
the INTP,
the I and t j and the Ian Tj.
Now just like to Ns,
we talk about in the last video and tps and Auntie J's May on the surface look
fairly similar,
but deep down the circuitry is fairly different and while they may share a
considerable amount of similarities,
they may be fairly different.
People will elaborate on the differences when we get into the cognitive
functions and just a couple of minutes here,
but for now,
what basic similarities do these types share that allow them to be categories in
the same category?
Well,
like all n nts are highly attracted to abstract concepts,
new possibilities and bake ideas.
They think outside the box very well.
They may have complex personalities and they trust their gut feeling over what
their immediate senses are telling them and they're particularly good at reading
between the lines of things when confronted with new information and an NT will
attempt to formulate the big picture first and then work out the components as
opposed to as to do the opposite and like all tease nts,
have a preference for making decisions based on objective criteria and their own
logical conclusions.
And we'll seek to exhibit this decision making style accordingly,
particularly in situations which I think you function of trucks and sue such as
the organization of the external world or the search for precision and truth and
are usually bright,
rational level headed,
independent and enthusiastic people having an interest in and in fact may in
hobbies out of subjects which they're fascinated in,
such as science,
math,
history,
philosophy,
et Cetera,
may make them appear somewhat geeky or nerdy on the surface,
especially as an a favorite participation in the subjects that were social
interaction.
At times,
even an extrovert's,
though they namely introverts may appear awkward or isolated at times.
They do tend to value human relationships though because of their weaker feeling
functions not always expressed very well.
However,
when it is expressed and t's May displayed and being gregarious with people that
are like being open to discussing a wide variety of subjects.
As mentioned,
nts have a preference for making decisions,
understanding concepts and living other lives in accordance with what makes
sense to them,
and it may tend to view emotions as something which gets in the way of this,
especially their own.
Accordingly,
if they can be shown that they are wrong,
they will often attempt to not take it personally.
However,
if they believe that a lot of conclusions are being criticized or challenge,
especially unnecessarily,
not only will they be quick to debate,
but they will often be very challenging debaters viewing it as an opportunity to
test and refine their own beliefs,
utilize their problem solving skills and accordingly often enjoy the process
that's based so long as it does not lead to bitter argument.
This is not to say that they are unpleasant people.
However,
aunties are usually laid back,
flexible,
unlikable,
and environments in which they're not stressed.
Then it'd be witty,
comical or attempt to be entertaining.
Sometimes it's entertaining.
Side isn't as funny to other types as it often involves pranks or humor,
which is intentionally confusing.
However,
in being a very independent type,
they are generally proud of their own originality,
very concerned about their free time,
maybe be very private and and welcoming of orders or manipulation and may react
to a fronts not only by argumentation but by leaving a situation entirely.
Like why is there a generally more respectful people's independence?
More so ntps in Ntj is honestly,
but we'll discuss that in a moment.
However,
on the negative side,
when stressed or unhealthy and t's may become argumentative,
cold,
defensive,
isolated,
caustic and irritable at times,
if their reasoning makes sense in their own heads and they'd be unwelcoming of
criticism or challenge or set of decisions and may try to ignore emotions and
their decision making process including their own,
when other's emotions are concerned that it may take great offense to this Nigga
Black Tan for them more.
When there are misunderstandings between NT and another person,
they may expect the other person to come to bridge that gap.
They may also be considerably suspicious of others and antisocial,
which may offend strangers and discourage people close to them considering their
own emotions.
Neglecting them can lead to stress and when a problem cannot be solved by what
normally makes sense to them,
then they shut down entirely.
Where other types would collect themselves like all intuitive types and they
have difficulty focusing on practical tasks such as house or car maintenance or
finances.
Antibodies,
especially while spending considerable amounts of times in their own heads and
may have its benefits,
it may be very stressful for them as these tasks go undone and life outside
passes by.
Furthermore,
while they may indeed be very original and fairly bright or they're thinking
habits and choices may make them appear to others to be egotistical or arrogant
or worse can lead to actual egoism and arrogance.
Assuming that people who think differently or our overall different are simply
not intelligent or worthwhile.
However,
most entities and not exhibit these traits commonly,
especially in extreme and as mentioned,
are generally easy going and likable.
There are systematic abstract thinking,
style,
desire for achievement and originality and wide ranger interest.
Often wines,
pumping fields at the sciences,
philosophy,
politics and economics,
engineering,
et Cetera,
and many notable figures within these fields we will see have been nts
throughout history.
So that's a sufficient introductory description.
However,
to continue,
we have to establish the differences between the Auntie J's and the NTPS.
And to do that,
we will of course,
house of look at the cognitive functions and like the Nfj isn't nfps.
In the last video,
like I said,
Auntie J's and NTPS did not share any cognitive functions.
So here are the four types.
Again,
the IMTJ,
the Emtj,
the INTP,
and the MTP,
and here are their cognitive functions.
So they're all entities because they're lead functions of both intuition and
thinking.
However,
as you can see here,
they're opposite focuses and tjs,
but for extroverted thinking and introverted intuition and ntps prefer intuit is
taking an extrovert intuition.
Likewise,
they're inferior functions as well are opposites and tjs are introverted.
Feelers and extroverted sensor is an ntps are introverted sensors and
extroverted feelers.
So on the surface these two types may act very similarly and may have similar
interests and hobbies,
et cetera.
But deep down they're circuitry is a little bit different.
What's the difference?
Well,
let's get into it.
Starting with intuition and Tj is prefer Ellis said Ann I introverted intuition
and ntps prefer extroverted intuition and he now we explained the same
difference in the Nfj is an nfps in the last video,
but we'll do it again here because the intuition and combination with the
thinking function,
which these types of for comes out a little bit differently.
False intuition functions are of course functions.
Folks focused on ideas,
concepts and possibilities,
but anti functions more on connecting concepts that fit a larger point,
a connects ideas as branches into a single tree,
I suppose you could say.
Whereas an he is more like a focus on a wide variety of ideas and concepts both
to create and understand.
So auntie J's are going to spend a lot of time trying to tie together what they
perceive to be true in their heads.
And while generally plays quite a bit of focus on the subject which they're
interested in.
They may just intuitively understand things and see patterns and things which
may go unnoticed to others.
It may have moments where it's described as sort of Eureka type moment where
things finally come together and understand things and you can almost see it in
their eyes when they piece something together like that and while anti explores
a variety of concepts,
generally this focus,
we'll leave them somewhat less interested in unrelated concepts and it may be in
fact somewhat critical of useless information.
This is what leads Ntj is to be fairly independent thinkers because they may be
equally critical of authority backed information such as schoolwork,
which other types of more responsive to and teas in general as a matter of fact
are classic examples of the old,
the teacher says I'm smart,
but lazy type kids and generally teachers actually do meanness with Aunties,
but with reference to Ntg A's and Tj is usually can function fairly well in a
very regimented and systematic and environment.
They just don't want to do that with school because they'd see it as outside of
their,
um,
their goals for their life and their style of thinking.
This function compliments we're thinking function,
extroverted thinking tee,
which Emtj is lead with an I and t J's follow with very well tee is a function
of focused on an efficient and logical organization of the external world.
NTPS which we'll discuss here in a moment with their ta in any may spend copious
amounts of time contemplating subjects more in depth,
but tea is more focused on utilizing information and making it applicable to
real world settings.
Then as I said,
they're an eye function is going to be consistently reviewing information and
enticing them to explore hunches and filtering out unnecessary ideas.
In such,
this accordingly draws into sciences and philosophy and politics and such
things.
A great number of contributors to these fields are and tjs as they're
exceptionally skilled with putting things together and making them work in the
real world with abstract topics especially,
but also of course in business,
the military or other organizations even in the household and with friends and
such,
they're good with graphs,
charts and means of organizing data like that.
They're more concerned with being effective than precise and even though they
may themselves be very independent and would prefer that others be independent,
they generally do well in positions of command.
This is why Auntie J's do so well on some of the high stress and not mentally
challenging environment.
If you're looking at CE and Tj is in particular have the highest average income
in the US and a great number of not only modern CEOs and such,
but in fact famous military leaders throughout history and Napoleon,
Cesar Alexander,
Gingiss,
et Cetera were ENT js and this is evident employing tee.
These four were all men who got right into the thick of battle and maintain a
cool head and we're quickly capable of figuring out what needed to be done.
The win and executing that plan,
whether actual combat or on the political scene or something like that.
Looking at an eye.
Each of these leaders were independent thinkers with grand designs.
This is again evidence on the battlefield.
Each of these men had tactics which were unique or revolutionary for the times
in fact,
but also in the design of their empires.
They weren't just going to sit back and be the dutiful Sga general who just does
what it needs to be done.
It goes through with their service.
No,
they were,
they took over their governments,
you know,
their nation's conquered major empire,
et cetera.
Things like that.
I and t J's are definitely noticeable on the seniors as well,
even if they're not so bold as they're extroverted counterparts at times in
terms of the country like Vladimir Lenin or in terms of a major company or
something like Elan Musk.
Elon Musk is another good example.
He's like,
leave less interested in studying the intricacies of human civilization and and
its effects on the world pass what is necessary and more interested in building
things which will have an impact on remodeling the world.
And directing his subordinates to follow through any and NTPS.
However,
it's more concerned as I studied with a variety of ideas and new possibilities.
Extroverted intuitors like ntps are constantly on the lookout for new ideas and
it become very interested in new concepts and naturally they're very good at
comprehending them quickly and in fact improving on them.
This focus on new intriguing concepts can make them seem like they jump from
topic to topic and this is certainly somewhat true.
We're an NTJ may focus on one thing like economics or the military or something
like that.
For an extent of time.
It might be astronomy one week,
maybe even for a couple of days and history for a bit and another language.
Probably Juggling a whole bunch of concepts at once and then coming back to them
at different times.
For an NTP,
it's not that they have a short attention span,
they're just comfortable juggling multiple subjects at once and in fact they
tend to prefer that accordingly.
Antibodies can be somewhat bothered by routine or unstimulating monotony.
You're practical tasks.
They may not only be capable or even above average skill at doing something like
their math homework,
but maybe putting a bunch of numbers through systems isn't as interesting as to
what they have decided to do with our time.
And that's not necessarily always that they have a preference for doing some
glory,
a big picture contemplation over the menial task and tribulations of the average
of life.
It's admittedly sometimes that they're just more interested in a video game over
housework,
but obviously who hasn't found themselves in that situation before,
but ntps especially may have to learn how to come back down to earth a little
bit more than they'd like to.
And of course,
NTP is preferred CEI introverted thinking Tiaa as concerned with systematizing
the world logically and impartially and consistently refining itself in order to
perfect the understanding of the world accordingly.
Tio leads like antibodies are very interested in systems and are very quick to
contemplate the components of something and decipher is core or solve an issue.
The Ai leads are also very precise and seek to convey ideas without confusion.
Stps generally,
we'll do this by being more laconic,
as I said in a previous video,
but ntps are not afraid to use a large vocabulary and we'll generally have
little patience for people who believe their vocabulary usage is used to
unnecessary fluff statement.
Furthermore,
ntps we'll have little patients or care for people who don't understand their
interest or flat out ignore their reasoning.
In general,
and t J's are like this as well,
but ntps usually communicate things by pulling from RTI framework and if it's a
complex matter,
the NTP may not express it very well,
even though it makes perfect sense to them in their heads and may simply choose
to forego explain the reasoning if they feel that others will not respect that
anyway,
which is something that MTPs have to work on.
Tia is essentially what makes ntps aspire it to be though are certainly not
always successful at beings.
US foc type character making decisions based on logic,
contemplating various concepts,
disregarding of irrelevant emotions,
et cetera.
Combined with intuition.
NTPS generally have a preference for exploring various and treating concepts and
ideas as opposed to their STP counterparts who prefer to explore the systems of
the practical world accordingly.
And Antiope we'll spend a lot of time in his or her head as their minds are
constantly generating ideas and t I leads and review them and we'll lead them to
hold internal debates about their logical consistency and likelihood and things
such as that.
An INTP,
especially maybe one of the most introverted people,
you know,
because it's been a lot of time in their heads on.
Although all intuitive types can sometimes feel like the real world is
interrupting their inner world,
Ntps may have the greatest preference for living in their internal world because
of these functions.
However,
as a result of this,
then we'd be satisfied with an idea making sense in their heads once all of its
aspects have been understood and not necessarily as focused as reproducing it in
the real world as an Ndj might be.
A perfect example of an NTP is Leonardo Da Vinci and ENTP.
So therefore of course and and elite key in any lead was immensely interested in
new ideas and concepts and field notebook upon notebook with a zone in the 15th
century.
A little over 500 years ago,
he created flying machines,
submarines,
tanks,
discovered heart disease,
et cetera.
He was a busy,
creative and logical dude though not many NTP share Da Vinci's Iq estimated to
be over 200 this ability to comprehend subjects and uncover that are internal
meetings,
think to why the NTP types had the highest Iq average.
However many of his inventions were never actually constructed Parsa because of
some unfortunate incidents in his life but also partially because it was
sufficient to him to know it would work.
Another example of the difference between an Ntj an NTP is Tesla and Einstein,
Tesla and I and Tj was interested in building things and inventing things and
restructuring the external world.
Einstein figured out a lot of things which are sitting of her phone but are more
abstract and involves contemplation and restructured the external world on a
more intellectual level and now the inferior functions and Tj is prefer
introverted feeling.
FII and ntps prefer extroverted feeling.
Effie,
if I,
as we have discussed as a function dedicated towards systematizing a set of
principles or values which the person feel that they must connect to in order to
feel truly like themselves.
Accordingly though it isn't a dominant trait,
NTJ is may at times make decisions and reinforce their reasoning with morals and
values and we'll have somewhat better understanding of their motion and focus on
what is right when they feel that they are right.
If I is,
because then it'd be very adamant about it and can make them seem stubborn.
However,
their ability to use fis of course not as developed as their NFP or SFP
counterparts and as the week of function and t J's May feel at times that they
don't know who they are deep down and make them,
it's some of their time trying to figure it out.
NTPS for for Effie extroverted feeling if he is what stops ntps from being as
harsh about their reasoning.
As auntie J's though it may make them seem as somewhat awkward or socially
anxious like I'll extrovert of feeders.
NTPS have a concern for how other people feel and how others feel.
Major directly impact their own emotions,
but may feel awkward and trying to accommodate other's feelings because of the
weakness of the function.
Lock in the natural,
know how that they're Nfj an SFJ counterparts have though group harmony is
important to them.
It's a feeling of others gives in the way of their law to her conclusions.
They will generally prefer their own reasoning to group emotion and harmony.
And as they're feeling is a weaker function and is extroverted.
They may have more difficulty dealing with their own emotions and may display
them seemingly awkwardly or an appropriately,
especially while under stress.
However,
they will display it healthfully while conversing with friends or at times and
expressing and emotional connection to the outer world and their place within it
through poetry or similar thing.
And last but not least,
ntps prefer as I introverted sensing and Auntie J's for as he extroverted
sensing as I the very first function we talked about in this series is dedicated
the categorization of facts and details about the immediate sensory world.
It works fairly interesting and MTPs as they use it to reinforce the functioning
of Tbi in any drawing on things which they've experienced or learned and
analyzing.
The trial and error mentality evolves with that PSI.
However,
as its function is introverted MTPs maybe less interested in being involved with
the external world,
which complements their desire to live inside of their heads fairly well.
And TJ is for,
for se extroverted sensing.
So there may be somewhat more athletic,
may be more where trends and such and they dress better and may have more of an
appreciation for the external world and living in the moment and accordingly
participating in the next in a world which complements and t very well as they
may impulsively and without hesitation drunk right into their plans or projects
and maintain a cool head within such situations.
So in conclusion and teas are rational,
bright,
independent minded,
enthusiastic,
creative and laid back.
People they enjoy learning about a variety of systems have a knack for solving
problems logically and reading in between the lines and are usually proud of
their originality and independence.
However,
they may have difficulty with others insight which are contradictory to what
makes sense to them,
especially where emotions are concerned and nts may have to learn to adjust
their rationale to fit values and ideal human relations taking into account the
emotions,
but as and learning to manage their own and Tcu improve themselves on these
drawbacks and capitalize on their talents have a full potential to make a big
difference in the world.
Now for some NT statistics and t's constitute 10.3% of the US population.
The INTP makes it a 3.3% the ENTP makes it a 3.2% the IMTJ makes up 2.1% and the
ENT j makes up 1.8% famous INTP is include Abraham Lincoln,
Charles Darwin,
Karl Marx,
Marie Curie,
and Tina Fey.
And also myself.
Not that I'm necessarily famous,
but anyway,
it miss ETPs include Benjamin Franklin,
Richard Fiman,
Socrates,
John Cleese,
and Stephen Fry.
Feminists Imtj is include Isaac Newton and Ran Friedrich Nietzsche,
Mark Zuckerberg,
and Patrick Stewart and famous e andJ is include Aristotle,
Julius Caesar,
Napoleon,
Bill Gates,
and Alexander Hamilton.
Well,
that's the nts in a nutshell.
And we have now covered all 16 types and a decent amount of depth as well as of
course videos explaining the cognitive functions and the NBTI letters.
But one big topic remains,
and it's kind of the elephant in the room,
how accurate,
consistent,
applicable,
and scientific is.
All of this stuff.
A lot of people are concerned that it's just the next strategy.
Some people think that it's maybe nice to know,
but ultimately useless.
So in the next video we'll be exploring the validity of Myers Briggs type
personalities and addressing counter arguments.
So stay tuned for more videos on subjects like this in a wide variety of other
ones.
Be sure to check out fire learning and subscribe.
Thank you for watching.